What I'd like to do now is look a few examples.
The first is file system testing and we've already talked about this a little bit,
so I'm not going to reintroduce this subject.
If we start with a simple file system tester, what we're probably going to do
is make a list of all the API calls that we'd like to test.
We can mount and unmount a file system, we can open and close a file,
we can create a directory and remove a directory, make list of all these kinds of functions,
and basically just call them randomly with random arguments.
Then, we'll look at the results and think about them
and we will see is that probably our testing is highly suboptimal because, for example,
if we're throwing unmount calls randomly into the max,
we're going to end up on average operating on an unmount file system at least 50% of the time.
Similarly, if there is no correlation in randomly chosen file names
between different calls to open-close and read and write and such,
we may effectively never actually perform a read or write call on an open file,
of course, that's obviously undesirable.
We're going to do then is, for example, first is special case mount and unmount.
We're also going to need to, almost certainly, special case open and close,
and namely, one thing that we might want to do is keep track in the random tester
of the set or currently open files.
And just these couple of simple things is probably enough to get a file system fuzzer off the ground.
But there's more, we probably want to limit the size of files
so we don't waste a lot of time writing many, many, many gigabytes to files
and we could be using that time better and perhaps
we also want to limit the height of the directory hierarchy
in order that we don't generate incredibly deep directory hierarchies that aren't interesting.
On the other hand, we may want to do exactly that.
we want to know exactly test extreme deep directory hierarchies or extremely large files,
but it might be the case that these are special cases that we want to test
separately from the main body of our fuzzer.
Okay, so what I hope is the general pattern is clear here. We start off doing something really simple.
We probably observed this doesn't work very well and then we start special casing things
in order to remove limitations of our random tester and, over time,
so maybe over weeks or months or even years,
This process ends up with a random tester that will be extremely strong.